Mais si vous devenez président du Zimbabwe,
et que vous dites : « Vous voyez, j'adore vraiment ce boulot.
Je pense que j'aimerais le garder pour toujours. »
(Rires)
Eh bien, vous pouvez.
Vous décidez d'imprimer des billets.
Vous appelez la banque centrale et dites :
« S'il vous plaît, doublez l'approvisionnement en billets. »
Ils diront : « Oui monsieur, y a-t-il autre chose que l'on puisse faire ? »
Voilà le pouvoir dont disposent les dirigeants africains,
et voici pourquoi ils font la vraie différence
sur le continent.
La bonne nouvelle,
c'est que la qualité du pouvoir politique en Afrique s'améliore.
Nous avons eu trois générations de dirigeants, selon moi.
La première génération est celle qui est apparue
dans les années 50 et 60.
Ce sont des gens comme Kwarme Nkrumah au Ghana
et Julius Nyerere en Tanzanie.
Leur héritage, c'est l'indépendance de l'Afrique.
Ils nous ont libérés du colonialisme,
et nous pouvons les en remercier.
Ils furent suivis par la deuxième génération.
Ce sont des gens qui n'ont rien apporté d'autre
que le chaos en Afrique.
Pensez à la guerre, à la corruption,
à la violation des Droits de l'Homme.
C'est le stéréotype du dirigeant africain que l'on s'imagine tous :
Mobutu Sese Seko au Zaïre,
Sani Abacha au Nigéria.
La bonne nouvelle, c'est que la plupart d'entre eux ont quitté le pouvoir,
pour être remplacés par la troisième génération.
Il s'agit de gens comme feu Nelson Mandela,
et la plupart des dirigeants aujourd'hui,
comme Paul Kagame et les autres.
Ces dirigeants sont loin d'être parfaits,
mais une chose qu'ils ont faite, c'est réparer une bonne partie des dégâts
causés par la deuxième génération.
Ils ont cessé les conflits,
et je les appelle la « génération stabilisante. »
Ils sont plus responsables à l'égard de leur peuple,
ils ont mis en place des politiques macro-économiques,
et nous voyons pour la première fois la croissance de l'Afrique,
qui est devenue la deuxième zone en termes de croissance.
Ces dirigeants sont loin d'être parfaits.
Mais ils sont en tout état de cause
les meilleurs dirigeants que nous ayons eus ces cinquante dernières années.
Alors, où cela nous mène-t-il ?
Je crois que la prochaine génération,
la quatrième génération,
a une opportunité unique
de transformer le continent.
Ils peuvent faire deux choses en particulier
que les générations précédentes n'ont pas faites.
La première chose qu'ils doivent faire,
c'est amener la prospérité sur le continent.
Pourquoi la prospérité est-elle si importante ?
Parce que les générations précédentes
n'ont pas pu s'attaquer au problème de la pauvreté.
L'Afrique aujourd'hui
a le taux de croissance démographique le plus élevé au monde,
mais aussi la population la plus pauvre.
D'ici 2030, l'Afrique aura plus de main d’œuvre que la Chine,
et d'ici 2050, elle sera le plus gros foyer de main d’œuvre au monde.
Un milliard de personnes auront besoin d'un emploi en Afrique,
donc si nous n'accélérons pas assez l'économie,
nous sommes assis sur une bombe à retardement,
pas seulement pour l'Afrique, mais aussi pour le reste du monde.
Laissez-moi vous donner un exemple
d'une personne qui se montre à la hauteur de cet héritage
et crée une certaine prospérité : Laetitia.
Laetitia est une jeune femme du Kenya,
qui, à 13 ans, a dû quitter l'école
parce que sa famille ne pouvait plus payer les frais.
Alors elle a lancé son affaire, un élevage de lapins,
qui sont un mets raffiné dans la région du Kenya d'où elle vient.
Son affaire a si bien marché qu'en un an,
elle employait déjà 15 femmes
et était capable de générer assez de revenus
pour retourner à l'école,
et, par le biais de ces femmes, financer l'éducation de 65 autres enfants.
Les bénéfices qu'elle a engrangés lui ont servi à construire une école,
et aujourd'hui elle participe
à l'éducation de 400 enfants dans sa communauté.
Elle vient d'avoir 18 ans.
(Applaudissements)
Voici un autre exemple, Erick Rajaonary.
Erick vient de l'île de Madagascar.
Un jour, Erick s'est rendu compte que l'agriculture
était la clé pour créer de l'emploi
dans les zones rurales de Madagascar.
Mais il a aussi compris que l'engrais était un gros investissement
pour la majorité des fermiers de Madagascar.
Au Madagascar, on trouve des chauves-souris très particulières
qui produisent des excréments très riches en nutriments.
En 2006, Erick a démissionné de son poste de comptable agréé
pour lancer sa propre entreprise de fabrication
d'engrais à partir de ces excréments.
Aujourd'hui, Erick est à la tête d'une entreprise
qui génère plusieurs millions de dollars de chiffre d'affaires,
il emploie 70 personnes à temps plein,
et 800 personnes de plus pendant la saison
durant laquelle les chauves-souris produisent le plus d'excréments.
Ce que j'aime dans cette histoire,
c'est qu'elle montre que les opportunités pour créer une certaine prospérité
peuvent être trouvées presque partout.
Aujourd'hui, Erick est appelé « Batman ».
(Rires)
Qui aurait cru que quelqu'un puisse créer une entreprise
qui vaut des millions de dollars et emploie autant de gens,
juste avec du caca de chauve-souris ?
La deuxième chose que cette génération doit faire,
c'est de créer des institutions qui nous appartiennent.
Ils doivent construire ces institutions
de façon à ce qu'on ne soit plus jamais sous le joug
de quelques individus, comme Robert Mugabe.
Tout cela paraît génial,
mais d'où va-t-on sortir cette quatrième génération ?
Va-t-on juste rester assis là en espérant qu'elle émerge par hasard,
ou que Dieu nous l'envoie ?
Non. Je ne crois pas.
C'est une question trop importante pour être laissée au hasard.
Je crois qu'il faut créer des institutions africaines, du cru,
qui identifieront et développeront
ces dirigeants de façon systématique et rationnelle.
C'est ce que nous faisons depuis dix ans
avec l'African Leadership Academy.
Laetitia est une de nos jeunes dirigeantes.
Aujourd'hui, nous en avons 700 comme elle qui sont éduqués
pour le continent africain.
Dans les 50 prochaines années,
nous pensons pouvoir en former encore 6 000.
Mais il y a une chose qui me dérange.
Nous recevions environ 4 000 candidatures par an,
pour 100 jeunes cadres que nous pouvions recevoir dans cette académie.
Alors j'ai compris l'incroyable demande qu'il y avait
pour cette formation.
Mais on ne pouvait pas répondre à cette demande.
Alors, aujourd'hui, j'annonce publiquement pour la première fois
la création d'une extension à cette vision qu'est l'African Leadership Academy.
Nous sommes en train de construire 25 nouvelles universités en Afrique
qui vont cultiver cette nouvelle génération
de dirigeants africains.
Chaque campus recevra 10 000 cadres à la fois,
de sorte que l'on éduque et développe
250 000 cadres à tout moment.
(Applaudissements)
Dans les 50 prochaines années, cette institution
va créer trois millions de dirigeants réformateurs pour le continent.
Mon vœu, c'est que la moitié d'entre eux
devienne ces entrepreneurs dont on a besoin,
qui créeront les emplois dont on a besoin,
et que l'autre moitié
ira au gouvernement
et dans le secteur non-marchand,
et construira ces institutions dont nous avons besoin.
Mais ils n'étudieront pas que de la théorie.
Ils apprendront également à devenir des dirigeants,
et ils développeront leurs capacités d'entrepreneurs.
Alors pensez-y comme la Sorbonne Africaine,
où au lieu d'être admis selon vos résultats aux concours,
ou grâce à l'argent dont vous disposez,
ou à votre famille,
le critère principal pour entrer à l'université
sera votre potentiel à transformer l'Afrique.
Ce que nous faisons ne forme qu'un groupe d'institutions.
Nous ne pouvons pas transformer l'Afrique à nous seuls.
J'ai l'espoir
qu'un tas d'autres institutions africaines natales naîtront,
et que ces institutions seront toutes formées dans le but commun de développer
cette génération de dirigeants africains à venir,
la quatrième génération,
et qu'elles leur enseigneront ce message général :
créez des emplois, construisez nos institutions.
Nelson Mandela a dit un jour :
« De temps à autre,
une génération est appelée à faire preuve de grandeur.
Vous pouvez être cette génération. »
Je crois que si l'on identifie et cultive avec attention
la prochaine génération de dirigeants africains,
alors cette quatrième génération qui est en devenir
sera la plus grande génération que l'Afrique,
et, en fait, le reste du monde, aient jamais vue.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)